جددت الشرطه السودانيه دعوه منسوبيها
بالمعاش والقادرين منهم على حمل السلاح
للتقدم اليها من اجل تامين الاحياء
والمناطق الحيويه واضافت انها نشرت
تعزيزات في ولايه الخرطوم لتوسيع الرقعه
التامينيه بالاسواق والمناطق الحيويه
والاحياء السكنيه منعا للتفلتات الامنيه
واكدت الشرطه السودانيه انها ماضيه قدما
للاطلاع بواجباتها المنصوص عليها في
القانون ونشر القوات بسطا للامن
من ناحيتها قالت قوات الدعم السريع ان
الجيش السوداني هاجم مباني سكه العمله في
الخرطوم واضافت في بيان على تويتر انها
تحمل قاده الجيش مسؤوليه ما سمته السلوك
العدواني ودان البيان استمرار ما سماها
الفلول في خرق اتفاق جده نصا وروحا مؤكدا
التزام الدعم السريع بالاتفاق